hi my name is Kaylee Bovie with the IBM
cloud team and today we're going to be
talking about virtualization as you know
virtualization is a fairly old
technology but it's still super relevant
to building our cloud computing strategy
today so first off what is
virtualization simply put virtualization
is the process of creating a software
based or virtual version of something
whether that be compute storage
networking servers or applications and
what makes virtualization feasible is
something called the hypervisor so we're
gonna write that here and what a
hypervisor is is it simply a piece of
software that runs above the physical
server or host and there are a couple
different types of hypervisors out there
and what they do is essentially pull the
resources from the physical server and
allocate them to your virtual
environments there are two main types of
hypervisors out there
one being type 1 very simple to remember
and 2 you guessed it type 2 so let's
start with type 1 a type 1 hypervisor is
a hypervisor that is installed directly
on top of the physical server they're
also called bare-metal hypervisor so
we'll write that up here just so you can
remember these are the most frequently
typed of views hypervisors and their
most secure they lower the latency and
these are the ones that you'll see in
the market the most some examples would
be VMware ESXi or Microsoft hyper-v or
even open-source KVM the other type of
hypervisor is a type 2 hypervisor over
here and what makes these different is
that there is a layer of host OS that
sits between the physical server and the
hypervisor
so by that nature they are also killed
hosted these are a lot less frequent
they're mostly used for end-user
virtualization and you might see some in
the market that are called like Oracle
VirtualBox or VMware Workstation
again there are a lot less frequent
there a bit more they have a higher
latency than a type 1 hypervisor so once
you have your hypervisor installed you
can build virtual environments or
virtual machines or simply put VMs so
let's spin up some environments so what
makes a VM a VM a VM is simply a
software based computer there run like a
physical computer they have an operating
system and applications and they're
completely independent of one another
but you can run multiple of them on a
hypervisor and the hypervisor manages
the resources that are allocated to
these virtual environments from the
physical server so because they're
independent you can run different
operating systems on different virtual
machines so you could run Windows here
or Linux here or UNIX here for example
and because they're independent they're
also extremely portable you can move a
virtual machine from one hypervisor to
another hypervisor on a completely
different machine almost as
instantaneously which gives you a lot of
flexibility and a lot of portability
within your environment so looking at
all of this this is the core
virtualization as a process so let's
talk about a couple key benefits that
you want to take away from this one cost
savings when you think about this and
the fact that you can run multiple
virtual environments from one piece of
infrastructure means that you can
drastically reduce your physical
infrastructure footprint this is
consolidation at its core and the fact
that you don't have to maintain nearly
as many servers run as much electricity
save a maintenance cost means that you
save on your bottom line
at the end of the day number two would
be agility and speed so like I said
spinning up a virtual machine is
relatively easy and quick a lot more
simple than provisioning an entire new
environment for your developers if you
if they say they want to spin up a new
environment so that they can run a depth
test scenario
whatever it might be virtualization
makes that process a lot simpler and
quicker and three lowers your downtime
so let's say that this host goes out
unexpectedly the fact that you can move
virtual machines from one hypervisor to
another on a different physical server
means that you have a great backup plan
in place right so if this host goes down
you can simply move your VMs very
quickly to another hypervisor on a
machine that is working so with this
this is really a virtualization today
and like I said at the beginning
virtualization is a technology that's a
few decades old at this point but it's
still super critical to understand for
your cloud computing strategy today
thanks for watching as we discuss the
basics of virtualization make sure to
subscribe below and give us a big thumbs
up if you liked this content